I'm Thunder does the pinpoint pass right  there and you really if your pal Gasol  you're throwing to the corner of the  backboard we're in that rubber where  chip rebounding team in the NBA of the  Thunder look at all the attention around  DeRozan average little home fake again  over that right shoulder  versus going faith honor 226 works on  animals  [Music]  my wife to take it Aldrich  my goodness is he shot the ball well  Marcus Aldridge is at the last to  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  once again how they gonna stop la when  he's just  [Applause]  three-point shot don't call our etern  rich all that traffic  beauty points for the doctor sovereignty  to the game here's dress coverage that  knocks  [Applause]  get to you saw a beautiful ping-pong  fifty-one  [Applause]